وسط مدينه واشنطن العاصمه تقف المحكمه
العليا شاهدا على حرك المجتمع الامريكي
عبر التاريخ في قضايا مصريه تهم الناخبه
الامريكي مثل الحق في الاجهاض او الحق في
اقتناء وحمل الاسلحه الناريه
وعندما تشتد الخلافه القانونيه بين
الامريكيين حول قضاياهم الاساسيه تكون
المحكمه العليا الملجئه الاخيره للاطراف
المتنازعه سياسيا او ليديا او اجتماعيا
باعتبارها اعلى هيئه قضائيه فيدراليه في
البلاد وحكمها النهائي هو الذي يجد طريقه
للتطبيق على الارض وانشات المحكمه العليا
من طرف اول كونجرسين في البلاد عام
1786جمعت لاول مره في عام
وتتكون المحكمه من رئيس القضاه وثمانيه
قضاه اخرين مساعدين وهم يبقون في مناصبهم
مدى الحياه ولا يتركون الا بالاستقاله او
الوفاه او العزل
وتبقى للدستور الامريكي فان الرئيس هو من
يرشح الشخصيات القضائيه التي يعتبرها قذره
على انجاز المهام ثم ياتي دور مجلس الشيوخ
المخول بالتصديق على تعيين القضاه
المرشحين من طرف الرئيس الذي اعدتا ما
يرشح الشخصيات التي تقترب منه السياسيا
وايديولوجيا
في الولايات المتحده تاريخ طويل من
القرارات والتفسيرات والاستنتاجات
القانونيه وعندما تطرح على المحكمه العليا
قضايا جدليه هو خلافيه بين الاطراف
السياسيه والمجتماعيه تجتمعوا المحكمه
للتداول في جلسات مغلقه بين اعضائها
القضاه قد يستغرق الامر عده اسابيع وفي
النهايه بصوت القضاه فيما بينهم داخل هذه
البنايه وراي لكل قاد من القضاه التسعه
صوت واحد في عمليه التصويت ويتم تمريره
قرار المحكمه بالاغلبيه واحيانا يكون
القرار بالاجماع بين القضاه التسعه من بين
القضايا الخلافيه التي طالما عجزت الراي
العام الامريكي هذا العام قضيته الاجهاض
الذي ضل حقا مقفولا لاكثر من 50 عاما في
يونيو الماضي وعكس كافه توقعات المنظمه
النسويه والحزب الديمقراطي وكثيرين في
البلاد قررت المحكمه العليا الغاء حقي
النساء في الاجهاض
وخلصت المحكمه في قرارها الى ان الامر
يعود بالكامل لولايه الاتحاد الفيدرالي
عليها ان تحدد اذا المسطره القانونيه
للاجهاض سبعه نقطات صوتوا للغاء ذلك الحق
فيما صوت القاضيان فقط لصالح الحفاظ عليه
وهو القرار الذي اثار جدلا واسعا في
المجتمع الامريكي واشتهرت المحكمه وايضا
هذا العام بقرار لها بشان ولايه نيويورك
وحقي حمل السلاح اقررت المحكمه ان قانون
الولايه الذي يطالب السكان برخصه قانونيه
لحمل السلاح الناري في الاماكن العامه
قانون غير دستوري ولا يحترمه حق الافراد